SCP-066 was once a wholesome, music-loving ball of
colorful living yarn known colloquially as Eric’s
Toy. However, while this came to the Foundation
as a relatively benign and friendly creature,
the actions of the Foundation itself
soon turned this anomaly sour.
During a test, a Foundation Researcher cut
a thread from SCP-066, causing it not only
considerable pain and distress but also making
it lose all trust in the Foundation. It went
from being a happy ball of ribbon that would
change into friendly forms like cats and produce
birthday cupcakes for researchers, to an angry
little twisted knot of wretched flesh-like twine.
It seems that SCP-066 holds a grudge for
the way it was treated too. Now it regularly
deafens researchers and guards in its proximity
with loud music in revenge for its mutilation.
Oh and why do they call it Eric’s Toy?
When it’s not producing ear shattering
music to mess with the researchers and other
anomalous effects, it can be heard saying
the name “Eric” in a deep, masculine voice,
though who this Eric is, we just don’t know.